[Music]
you can't just go along with what people
are saying Susan okay
there's no scientific proof no real
evidence of a manbearpig well there's a
lot of smart people saying manbearpig is
real yeah and a lot of smarter people
saying it isn't okay what you need to
understand Susan is that everyone has an
agenda
okay everyone wants to use the fear of a
manbearpig to get what they want they
roll around bad science bad taxidermy
people coming out of the woodwork or now
experts on the subject you can't just
let people tell you that if you don't
believe in member pipng you don't care
about the world you want to believe it's
real you go right on ahead soon
okay manbearpig is real what are we
gonna do about it now what are we gonna
do that's gonna make any difference now
Susan what can we do that everyone else
will also do shoot come on use your
brain
you